Michael Jordan said one thing to Julian
Edelman at a dinner many years back and
what he said was pretty hilarious to us
but definitely scary as hell for Edelman
at the time so it's the week before
Edelman and the Patriots are playing in
the Super Bowl in 2014 he goes out to
dinner with his family when he runs into
Michael Jordan and Derek Jeter also at
the restaurant Edelman described Jeter
as a nice Charming guy but he described
MJ as very standoffish Edelman said that
right when the conversation was wrapping
up MJ pulled Edelman in and told him
quote Hey kid I've got a bunch of money
on you don't up Edelman said he had no
idea what to respond so he just said yes
sir Mr Jordan Edelman went on to score
the go-ahead touchdown and the Pats
ended up winning the Superbowl so he's
probably good in MJ's book for life